hello good morning
uh this is uh srinivasa sridhar from
boston
uh and uh
i it is my pleasure to tell you about uh
um our work
in the area of nano technologies for
precision medicine
with a focus on cancer
i am presently the director
of the nano medicine science and
technology center and also distinguished
professor of physics bioengineering and
chemical engineering at northeastern
university
and i also hold an appointment
in the department of radiation oncology
at harvard medical school
so this talk i'm going to be uh
discussing
our
applications uh our of nanotechnology in
um cancer
um i do want to mention that um
i have created a small poll to
understand the makeup of this present
audience
i am now going to push that poll out to
you
and um
uh and uh
this is this poll is intended to uh you
know get a feeling for
uh the composition of the audience uh
please respond i'm gonna leave it open
throughout the talk
and then i will publish the poll at the
end of the um
at the end of the lecture
so
the um
so in order to give you a bit of a
context in which this work is being done
at northeastern university i the nano
medicine science and technology is part
of the electronic materials research
institute that i started in 2005
the key trusts of the center and the
institute are research primarily in nano
medicine
we have a strong portfolio in education
in nanomedicine
that i will tell you about at the end of
this talk
we have established a nanomedicine core
facility that is critical to
the work that i will describe to you and
uh the other key aspect of our um the
institute in the center are the
partnerships
um these are
not only local with the
hospitals uh
in the boston area and as you know
uh we have one of the biggest medical
research complexes in the world uh and
we're right uh a part of it
near the longwood area in boston
but
in addition we collaborate with
industry
uh and academic partners not only
nationally but also internationally
so
uh
one of the critical aspects to the work
i'll just uh i'll describe to you is the
ability to
uh
to characterize nanomaterials for
medical applications and we have an
extensive
facility at northeastern that we've
established over the last several years
that is used not only internally but
also externally
and so the typical things that we test
for this is uh as far as the physical
chemical properties go are listed on the
left left here
uh and on the right i list some of the
technologies that the instruments that
are used to
um
test these properties uh i have not also
included here but that's also a part of
the work
the in vitro uh characterization
facilities and our in-vivo
animal studies but i will be showing you
results on that
uh during this lecture
these are some of our partners uh that
have uh
uh we have worked with
over the years i want to particularly
acknowledge the top line where i list
our sponsors over several years um
and
then there are various the hospitals and
then
other companies and
universities
now i want to start this talk
by telling you
why is nanotechnology
relevant now
uh in action in in the context
of
uh
medicine
this i would say
has crystallized over the last 10 years
um which is when we started you know our
nano medicine program here
uh and so there are
actually there are a
couple of uh
historical reasons
uh or trends which have enabled
nanotechnology to be applied to medicine
today
and the first
is let's look at the
the sizes of various objects
on the top i show you
the sizes of various naturally occurring
entities
for instance the dna base and the dna
turn is around three nanometers
uh then you get two proteins you're then
in the ten 10
to 100 nanometer size range these are
large biomolecules
viruses are larger entities
um and bacteria are several microns and
and bacteria and cells are much uh are
microns and larger and of course i could
have extend this on
to
um
organisms and um
and and on to humans and the largest
mammals
such as elephants so nature
has the biological uh biologically
relevant entities in nature span the
range from a tenth of a nanometer onto
several meters
now
what has happened over the last uh
50 years or or so
and that is accelerating
um
uh
on a daily basis
is that
we are able to make
uh synthetically uh
controlled structures
at um
on the nanometer scale ranging from less
than 10 nanometers
onward to
uh
several microns and i list some of these
nanoparticles here gold nanoparticles my
cells
nano assemblies
liposomes and so on and beyond that
these can further be
uh assembled
into larger structures as
we have shown here
now
uh and this is really the development uh
that has occurred over the last several
years that has enabled uh nanotechnology
to be applied uh to medicine but this is
only one of them
so the nanotechnology revolution
that
has occurred has essentially three parts
to it
one is
the ability to design nanostructures and
i show you here a couple of
um
entities which are
this is a dna template
a dna based nanostructure
and then these are some other
biomolecules
uh and and on
you know we now have the ability to
actually dial in capabilities and
construct various uh structures and just
design them well if you design them you
can also the next is to be able to make
them so making nano is the next step in
the
nanotechnology revolution
uh
these are done primarily in two ways
one is
top-down nanolithography
uh which is um and the other is
bottom-up self-assembly now in the top
here i have shown
it's a photonic crystal structure that
we made in my lab this is
a using you know conventional
nanolithography where you cut down from
large sizes on down
the other this is a micellar structure
and we're looking at the core of the
micelle
this is done from bottom up self
assembly
and uh what we uh
so here uh you start by
putting this is largely wet chemistry
and you put together the constituents
and if you have the right conditions you
will achieve the structures that you
need and i'll show you some examples of
structures later on
now it's not enough just to design
manual
and it's not enough just to make nano
you also want to be able to see men
and that's the third leg of the
revolution that has occurred
um
the
what is critical today to this kind of
work
is the availability of a range of
microscopes
atomic
electron
optical
and i show you here two examples of
using these microscopies uh it is so
routine now to take make nanostructures
run them over to an uh
an sem or tm
in order to under to characterize them
and look at their
their morphology
so
what
um
so with this what is nano medicine nano
medicine
is the application
of
uh nanotechnology
to
challenging medical applications
and
i believe and and so do a lot of other
people
and including the
you know the funding agencies and also
um
the
governments across the world
that nanomedicine is poised to make
major
contributions
to
uh
to
therapy and diagnostics
and so what are the key
applications of nanomedicine
they include in vitro diagnostics
here are some examples of
quantum dots you in cells
um so that you can look at
cellular processes
um
in vivo
imaging and diagnostics i've only showed
one part of that here
which is
um
imaging using
nanoparticle contrast agents
uh and i'll show you an example of that
later on uh this cannot but you can also
do
x vivo diagnostics where you know you do
blood
draws of body fluids and then
run them through
for biomarkers and in the process
nanotechnology
almost always plays a part
in
one of the critical areas
is the ability is
the
ability to deliver
drugs
and other biological entities to the
disease site and for that nanotechnology
is
absolutely essential
the
um the uh
and and these are exam and i will show
you our work in this area
and this is all led to the concept of
theranostics that is
um
multifunctional platforms that combine
both diagnostic capabilities
and often carry
various entities it could be drugs they
could be
entities that can
be used to deliver energy
uh so that you can
do
uh both diagnostic
diagnostic imaging and therapy
so these are
this leads to the
uh concept of nano platforms
or precision medicine
um and this and this has three
components to it
firstly
early diagnostics i think everybody in
this audience appreciates the importance
of
diagnosing cancer
as early as possible today we
diagnose cancer at anatomical signatures
um
that is you know millimeter size tumors
or larger
what we need to do is to catch it
now at that time millimeter size tumors
is something like a billion cells
we need to catch it uh when it's much
smaller maybe at a hundred cells
so how uh or a thousand cells even so
how how are we going to get that million
fold improvement and that is primarily
going to come from
nanotechnology approaches
now once you've diagnosed the tumor you
obviously you want to avoid
the uh the systemic toxicities that are
really complete feature
of
um
therapy today i mean
you know i think you all understand that
um when you think of cancer therapy you
think of
the first image that comes to mind is oh
hair loss and and that's a totally
irrelevant consequence it has nothing to
do with the disease it just only has to
do with the therapy cancer therapy today
is defined
by toxicity
um and so you have the concept of you
know mtd
maximum tolerated dose
rather than
the efficacy
of
the therapy
and
in order to improve
the
the therapy clearly
targeted therapies are essential and
nanotechnologies play a critical role in
this
hopefully once you know the idea is that
you diagnose the disease you
um you then administer your drug it
concentrates in the disease side
now after this you want to do real-time
monitoring
and
um for that
again nano platforms play
will play a critical role uh
i'll
there
this is an area that is an emerging area
uh and uh
i'll talk about some of the ways in
which this can happen
and of course our hope is that the end
your uh the patient will emerge disease
free
so in order to achieve this we need
several levels of precision we need
geographical positions so that you can
home in on the two on the tumor you need
cellular position because you may want
to
um
address you you may want to
to target
subcellular organ
organelles like i mean
mitochondria or the nucleus
and beyond that even when you
have achieved your subsetter you want to
target specific molecules for instance
genes
or
inhibitory pathways
and so there are several levels of
precision medicine
that can be addressed by
nanotechnologies
so
i um
so how so you know the way we proceed
about uh nanomedicine research is
actually we start with a medical
challenge whether it is
um for instance for precision tumor
targeting
or radiation oncology which is one area
that i work in and i will talk about
um
or localized energy delivery for
instance
uh
deliver triggered uh
hyperthermic chemotherapy
or hyperthermia for instance
um so we start with a medical challenge
uh and then we go backwards from that
uh and we designed the nano platforms
and at northeastern
we have a whole range of nano platforms
that we have developed i would say more
than 50
or maybe even approaching 100
these include polymers lipids organelles
various self-assembling amphiphiles
magnetic nanoparticles is a an area that
we have worked on extensively
metallic nanoparticles like gold
i will give you examples of how they're
used both of them quantum dots now
quantum dots are really primarily for x
vivo
um because as they are at present
they contain heavy elements and they are
not going to be used in
humans
we are
working on developing some green quantum
dots
and
this doesn't is not restricted only to
um
to
nanoparticles we also
have
developed and there's another large area
of application which is
nanoporous coatings on implants
and basically preparing uh implants
uh
to be biocompatible uh to do drug
delivery and things like that
now if you make them you have to
characterize them and so we have an
extensive toolkit characterization
toolkit i mentioned briefly earlier
now all of this of course has to at the
end use some form of biology
and it may be apoptosis
uh it could be i mean endocytosis is one
of the common meth mechanisms of
nanoparticle uptake
um
and and but that is primarily used to
get the drug
or your biologic into the cell
then you may
want to do gene silencing
and use
short interference rna for instance
and si rna is typically delivered with
nanoparticles
uh so you do have to have an
understanding of the biology
in order to use these nanoparticles
in order to achieve the medical
challenge that you
are aiming to
address
so i will run through some examples of
this in this talk
um and
so this talk is gonna be essentially in
three parts
the first is i'll show you something
applications of nanotechnology for
radiation oncology
um
and i'll talk about two uh
developments that have occurred in my
laboratory one is smart implants for
local chemo radiation therapy
and the second is gold nanoparticles for
radiation that'll use to enhance
radiation therapy
then i'll talk about multifunctional
magnetic theranostic nanoplatforms uh
and how they're used in mr contrast
enhancement magnetic targeting uh
magnetic
triggered chemotherapy
in in multi-modal imaging
um
and then finally i i'll mention briefly
our efforts in nanomedicine education
and training
we have established the first
nanomedicine
doctoral
program uh since 2005 at northeastern
university
and um
and uh that has already graduated
several trainees and we're developing
new programs
and i'll briefly summarize them at the
end
so
um let's start with this and
um i i want to start with part one which
is nanotechnology for radiation oncology
uh we have several this is a close
collaboration between northeastern
university
uh primarily my center the nanomedicine
science and technology center
the dana farber cancer institute
and
brigham and women's hospital uh this is
a collaboration led by
mike macro gorgos and dana farber and
myself
our primary
projects are part inhibitors
for chemo radiation therapy
local chemotherapy which is also
we call it biological institute image
guided radiation therapy gold
nanoparticles
and the more general issue of
radiogenome radiation genomics and
genomic instability
i will primarily talk about these
these middle two topics
there are several
accomplishments of this
um and you can also find a link to this
in my website
so
uh
the first part of this talk uh in the
first part of the nanotechnology for
radiation
oncology
this is work we're done with several uh
people
some of whom are rajiv kumar robert
cormack mike
michael gorgos anthony demiko paul
newman and myself
in radiation uh therapy
the uh there are two principal ways of
uh treating cancer and as you may know
roughly sixty percent of cancers are
actually treated with radiation
so it is a very commonly used modality
and
uh the one
the two typical approaches are one is
external beam
radiation therapy and the other is
brachytherapy where small seeds are
placed
in the
uh
in the disease site
particular whether it is the prostate or
breast or a variety of
other solid tumors also
this is done through an image guided
procedure
and these procedures have been well
developed and and they're
well established and essentially part of
the armament of the radiation oncologist
now
both of these procedures
use
um
some kind of a
marker in the external beam it's a
fiducial marker it's a gold pin
in the case of brachytherapy they use
small spacers besides the radioactive
seeds
the question we asked and we have
addressed is can we make these
spacious
spacers and fiducials which are
currently inert
all this the only purpose they serve
is
for
uh
geographic location you know here you
want to know where where's the tumor
and here
you want to space out the seeds
so they serve no other purpose
we want to make them smart
by
releasing drugs and biologics that will
enhance the radiation therapy
but the same procedure can be used
without radiation also so that it can be
used entirely for local chemotherapy
so
what we have designed and and developed
and
have deployed in pre-clinical
experiments
are
what we call
insert implants
these are implanted the insert stands
for implantable nanoplatform
for chemo radiation therapy
this work is primarily done by rajiv
kumar and jody bells along with our
collaborators at danofarver
so what we have here is um
we take a spacer the brachytherapy
spacer
which is typically
shown here here is a commercial spacer
it's typically around
eight millimeters
long and about
one millimeter in diameter
here is our drug drug-loaded
spacers um with two forms one is
uh it's an encapsula physically absorbed
in here we have conjugated system
so what is inside here in these uh
loaded platforms are
usually nanoparticles
um
they may be of various types
this example here talks of silica
nanoparticles
what happens is that
when these are placed in the tumor
the uh
matrix degrades it releases the
nanoparticle which then releases the
drug so this is a dual release platform
um
and
um
the
the key point is that the release is
over many many days as you can see here
uh we have
watched this over 30 and even longer
days
and the reason for this is we want the
drug release to be synchronous with
the
half-life of the radioactive seed which
is around
60 days
you can see here
that we put a dye into these spacers and
put them in a mice and you can see how
they're visible even up to 14 and even
actually we've carried this on to many
more days so they sit there and release
slowly
well
well does this have any therapeutic
benefit and so that i show here
um
we have carried out a whole uh a
fairly thorough
um
animal study um
and i will uh so we have done the
treatment groups are
control
no treatment
blank spacer
one dose of taxo tear or dosa taxo so
the what we're using here is dosataxo is
the
prior is the frontline chemotherapeutic
for prostate cancer
after
uh typically after radiation
um
and also in conjunction with radiation
uh so we use give one dose of um
dose attack cell and
and then that's in one group and then
the last group is with the spacer then
we also do blood chemistry
so here are the results
you can see here
um the controls of course the tumor so
this is tumor volume over days the
control grows
you know without
control and then typically we have to
sacrifice the amount the animals here
the single dose of
dosa taxo
the iv administration also does not
arrest the tumor and you will see that
it has some nasty
toxicities
the uh
on the other hand the drug loaded spacer
not only arrests the tumor it actually
then if you extend this on it shrinks it
and we have animals that are now tumor
free for more than 120 days
this shows you the toxicities
um you can see that
uh the
the
drug that
spacer implanted animals are very
healthy
uh in fact they increase weight
uh whereas when you with these the
dosataxel injection immediately you get
a hit
and this hit lasts for days now
in fact in humans once you give the
therapy the dosataxel you have to wait
two weeks because the patient is heavily
neutral
and then only you can administer again
um
so the drug however if it's administered
iv clears out within a day whereas with
the spacer it is acting continuously
so does this have so how does this all
play out you know in as regards survival
um
at 40 days
um
we have
um
for the local
chemotherapy group with the spacer
implanted 89 of the mice arrive at 40
days whereas
with the control and with the iv dose
attack cell there's zero percent
survival at 40 days
and uh here is the uh
here's how the mice look uh you can see
that for the spacers
at four weeks the tumor is gone there is
a um
ulcer which also clears out
at eight weeks post treatment
for both the dosa iv and the
control um the tumor is growing um
and
more importantly you can also see here
these animals are really weak
uh the iv dosataxel is is very weak uh
due to the heavy neutropenia
so
um
i so this is very promising results for
um
for uh the local chemotherapy this is uh
i should have added that this is pc3
tumors in mice and because we primarily
see the the first start application in
prostate cancer so what are the
advantages of this
we're delivering drug locally
it's sustained
uh delivery over
over
many days
typically 60 days
whereas when you give inter
chemotherapy
systemic administration is given
intermittently you can tailor the
release profile
to synchronize with radiation therapy we
can give
we can you do local dose multiplication
that is where 100 of the drug is in the
tumor
and importantly we completely avoid the
systemic toxicity
so the
importantly there's no important
additional inconvenience to the patient
because this procedure is already
happening is already in place
and
you can use it without radiation but
with radiation the idea is to reduce the
radiation dose to get a bigger bang and
those are experiments that are ongoing
next
so this
cartoon summarizes if you give
intermittent with chemotherapy systemic
you have to give you know spikes but
here you get sustained chemo radiation
synchronize
the
the
chemotherapy is
sustained and synchronized with the
radiation
we can put in any number of other
biologics and
we can all and then there in addition to
prostate cancer there any number of
other
cancers where brachytherapy is also used
that we can use this process
so
i am now completed uh talking about
part 1a of my talk this is these are
some of the publications you can look
them up
and i now want to move on to
part 1b
which is gold nanoparticles as radiation
sensitizers
what happens here is that
the
uh
the re so if you have gold nanoparticles
and you have radiation hits them
not only is it the radiation acting on
the rest of the tissue
but
the gold nanoparticles will release
electrons
which will then lead to reactive oxygen
species
and lead to additional cell kills
so we have shown in calculations
that
you can get an enhancement of as much as
a factor of three
when you add gold nanoparticles
um
and they are located in the tumor
particularly in the epithelium
so this is a very promising way of
sensitization
and uh we have developed now third and
even fourth generation nanoparticles
which uh it's a it's a complex structure
where we have gold nanoparticles with a
polymer brush for long circulation
they have peptides to
target the
the tumor
here is a sc the transmission electron
microscope of the nanoparticles
here they are in cells they enter cells
very nicely uh we had a fluorophore that
you can see here you can see inside the
cells this shows the in vitro radio
sensitization and basically when you
combine
gold nanoparticles and radiation you get
complete cell kill
and the enhancement of the cell kill is
shown here
uh with a significant boost
so
um
what i show here are that these
the the nanoparticles nicely target
tumors both in
orthotopic pancreatic cancer and in
transgenic lung cancer models
and so we now have the gold
nanoparticles at the tumor site
and we're now doing irradiation studies
in order to see the efficacy in vivo we
have already demonstrated in vitro
now i want to turn to part two of my
talk and i'm gonna have to speed up
because this is um
so as to finish on time
so
the next part is we've developed
theranostic magnetic nanoplatforms uh we
start with iron oxide nanoparticles and
that's because
these are
um
biocompatible we have a large number of
nanoparticles but they're not really
um
and magnetic nanoparticles they're
biocompatible uh
their biocompatibility
is um
uh uh
is very important and iron oxide are
stabbed well established
the
now
as by themselves they're
they're not any good for in vivo
administration so we have to do a whole
bunch of functionalization
the
uh we have put gold on them
uh and this is to
to be able to use the tile
binding of um gold
we have put polyelectrolytes to control
their charge we have put uh various
entities uh
like
antibodies on them
and we have encapsulated them into
several
platforms this is a nano emulsion
uh and this is a micelle
and this is a
core shell system these three are they
have hydrophobic cores
so that they can be used to encapsulate
hydrophobic drugs like texans
the other uh
major carrier
for magnetic and other
entities are liposomes and we have made
magnetic nanoliposomes um
and these these actually can be used for
both hydrophobic drugs like adriamycin
and also hydrophilic drugs
so the way
uh
the liposomes are lipid bilayers and
they are really wonderful carriers
because
they have an aqueous core where you can
put in aqueous drugs like adriamycin
you can put um hydrophobic drugs
in the
uh lipid bilayer and and uh
you know we have encapsulated a variety
of hydrophobic drugs like taxans
we have attached so typically they
always have a polymer brush
we have attached radio labels
um
the we have attached
fluorophores we have attached antibodies
and there's a large number of
publications on this
um
so we have made a whole range of uh
we have encapsulated a variety of drugs
including doxorubicin wind blasting
etophyside
um
gdnf
and also si rna so these are used for
magnetic targeting
um
the
um
and and we can do that through charge
and through magnetism
uh we can do we've delivered various
drugs
and we can do multimodal imaging
now i'm gonna take a second here and uh
just note which something i should have
told you before
if you want uh this is a cme accredited
event
and you can click on the cme button
on the lower left to get credit so this
is just a reminder for those who want to
get a cme credit for this
okay back to liposomes
so
um
these are very efficient drug delivery
vehicles and
my collaborator bob campbell has shown
that you can deliver vinblastine
uh in a
b16 um
f10 melanoma model
and you can target
by applying a magnet you can target the
drugs to the tumor
uh and i'll show you some an example of
that in a second
and when you do that the tumor is
completely arrested
uh and you essentially
uh
and it also minimizes uh and eliminates
medicine metastasis
so by magnetic targeting you can
complete you can greatly improve the
treatment outcome
this is shown we actually visualize this
here
uh and this is published in this paper
so on the left you have
uh
a a control mouse
uh well uh where we there's a tumor here
on the flank uh again this is a melanoma
model you
we administer the liposome magnetic
liposome with
vinblastine
and you can see that it accumulates in
the tumor through a process
and i should have i should mention this
nanoparticles accumulate in tumors
passively
uh through a process called uh
the enhanced permeability and
and retention effect where essentially
they leak they
leak out of the leaky vasculature so
they extravasate out of the leaky
vasculature into the tumor
so you get some
enhancement in that however when you
then put a magnet on it you know here uh
and you leave it only for one hour you
actually get a multiplication of a
factor of three
so magnetic guidance increases the tumor
accumulation when you have magnetic
liposomes
uh by a factor of three and you get much
greater drug
so
ah now i think this is an important
point going back to that issue of
drug targeted therapy we can go if you
typically administer a drug
less than a tenth of a percent or so
accumulates in the tumor
with passive targeting you can get up to
a few percent typically
with additional things like antibodies
or magnetic targeting here you can
actually get up to 15 percent
and so now we've got significant
uh drug delivery um accomplished
and so instead of
almost improvements of anywhere from 10
to 50 times
now
these
magnetic liposomes can also be radio
labeled
and they're very efficient spec imaging
agents as you can see here
um
now
one thing i wanted to tell you is that
typically so how does so how does
going back to this
how do we visual how are we visualizing
the magnetic nanoparticles here
uh and that is because through it what
happens in in this kind of conventional
imaging is
the
um the nanoparticles go dark
uh make the area surrounding them go
dark so you have negative contrast here
uh this is the the way this works is
that
uh the nanoparticles affect the
uh the uh
water around them
and so they make they
greatly reduce the relaxation rate
um
and increase the relaxation time
so it stops responding and you see a
dark spot where the nanoparticles are so
that's how
magnetic nanoparticles act as
contrast agents however we have now
developed a process
where we can get positive contrast so
you can see here
that
before the injection of the
nanoparticles magnetic nanoparticles you
can see essentially nothing
uh with this technique which is we call
it qte for quantitative ultra short time
to echo using contrast enhancement
when you inject the nanoparticles you
can see beautiful
vasculature being rendered everywhere
the nanoparticles distribute completely
in the blood and you can see them
uh exquisitely
we have shown that not only can you
visualize them but you can actually do a
quantitative assay and that is
in this paper in magnetic resonance in
medicine that just came out earlier this
year
and i refer you to that
we're doing a lot more with this uh in
both uh
you know
vascular imaging throughout the body and
also in the brain
um now i want to briefly touch upon
another system because um we can do
something more with magnetic and
nanoparticles
that is described here
we have this is a core shell system uh
that was published
in this paper in theranostics
um
and
uh the key point is these are well very
reliable nanoparticles but what's
important is that if you take these
magnetic nanoparticles
you put them in an ac magnetic field
then they can you deliver energy to the
magnetic nanoparticles absorb energy
and then they that breaks it breaks up
the nanoparticle and releases the drug
and that is shown here in uh
in vitro experiments
um
so that you know you can see
um
with just five minutes of this
of this heating
and it's not really a temperature rise
by the way it's only
it just delivers local energy
um you can see a release and then 20
minutes later you get more of the drug
uh
released from these nanoparticles
and so now you can actually
so what we have shown
uh which gets me to the next point here
is that
with these nanoparticle systems
we can
do
we can deliver
a whole range of
uh
chemotherapeutics biologics
uh and i didn't get into others we're
delivering parp inhibitors
to the disease site we can get them
there through passive targeting uses the
enhancing using the enhanced
permeability and retention effect
we can do it with antibodies and
peptides
i showed you the example of peptides in
the
radiation oncology
with the gold nanoparticles
and we can do it magnetically with
magnetic nanoparticles
so we can get these to the disease site
they will then
release by themselves
uh through enzymatic degradation
or uh you can actually deliver energy uh
locally and break up the nanoparticles
to do triggered release
and then you can combine it with
radiation therapy and actually any
number of other therapies like
photodynamic therapy focused ultrasound
and so on
so we can do all of these
therapies we can also simultaneously
monitor the nanoparticles
with
mr i showed you mr spect and optical
uh we we've also uh conjugated pet
ligands uh so that you can do multimodal
imaging and there's a reason for this
and the primary reason is today if you
go to the uh operating room of the
future at mass general and brigham and
women's hospital they have combined mr
and pat
but the markers are on the table here we
can get the fiducial markers
which are these multimodal nanoparticles
in the uh person
inside in the aorta
and not on the table so that greatly
improves things like registration so
this is the sort of overview of
multifunctional nano platforms
for precision image guided therapy that
we're pursuing in my center
i chair the nanoparticle imaging working
group at the national cancer institute
and we recently published a paper that i
will refer you to that discusses all the
advantages of
nanoparticles in imaging
and however in order for the
nanoparticles to get to the clinic there
are several barriers that need to be
overcome and these barriers are also
described there
in the paper and briefly in this in our
summarized in this slide
now
um
so that completes the research portion
of this talk
and i want to move to my third topic
not only are we researchers we're also
educators
and i'm
passionately committed to nano medicine
education i started the first
interdisciplinary nano medicine program
anywhere in the world
at northeastern university
thanks to funding from the national
science foundation
um and uh
we won the award first in 2005 when nano
medicine was not even a well-known name
uh and
then
um
the uh
the uh
and then we won it again in 2010
uh and so we will continue this on and
now we're gonna establish a standalone
nanomedicine phd uh the first of its
kind anywhere in the world starting in
next year 2015.
um this is in collaboration with several
institutions the key highlights are
shown here
um we have we have trained 45 phds and
more than and much actually more than 36
um
bs and ms trainees this is a truly
interdisciplinary program
we actually now have developed four new
courses
uh you can see all of this in my website
listed here and i'll show that at the
end
um and these are some of our
graduates we're very proud of them
they've gone on to
uh you know very successful careers
now that was primarily doctoral we got a
new we have thanks to a new brand from
the national cancer institute we're also
now training undergraduates so that they
will be
so we're establishing the pipeline to
train the next generation of cancer
researchers and clinicians
so i'm gonna close here
um
and
um i wanna uh
first of all thank my numerous
collaborators
and sponsors
these are
my collaborate principal collaborators
at northeastern uh they're actually many
more students who also contributed
i want to mention my principal
collaborators at the hospitals they're
critical to our um they bring the
medicine to this
and everything i do is in close
collaboration with clinicians
and of course the funding agencies uh
who have made this work possible um
these are the various
the the the centers
uh and institutes at northeastern that
have made that under which this work is
done
so i wanna
uh first of all thank you all for
listening
um and
uh you can find further information at
these two websites
and you can write to me
um i'll be happy to to
you know hear
be very interested to hear from you
offline also
now i want to first of all
close the poll
and
um
and then i guess i'm going to try and
push the results out
so
to give you an idea um 67 percent of the
audience two-thirds of the audience is
uh our basic researchers ten percent are
clinician clinical researchers
i
there are no clinicians as such uh on on
the in this audience and then there are
several who do not fit into this
category any of the above categories
um so i'm gonna close this also
and
uh i would next
i would like to address some of the
questions
so let me um
scroll through here
um there are several questions that have
showed up
um
and uh let me
start with uh some questions
so
look through here and um
so let me go through these ques try to
con look at these questions
so let me um
let me start with a question here
on the dimensions
of the gold nanoparticles so the
question is
what are the
uh gold nanoparticle i mean what is the
dimension of the gold nanoparticles and
uh just one second while i'm trying to
see whether
um
i can uh see the rest of the question
um
okay so i i can see a part of the
question which is um
what uh what is the dimensions so that
the gold nanoparticles themselves are
around 20 to
so
20 nanometers or less
i want to add that
anything below five nanometers will get
cleared out
uh
yes i'm sorry the question is visible
here
uh what about the dimension of
nanoparticles related to the toxicity
within biolog biology systems and that's
a good question
the gold nanoparticles are
we make several types ranging from two
nanometers to 20 nanometers anything
less than five nanometers actually gets
excreted out through the uh is urinated
out so through the renal system
anything bigger is retained inside the
body now
gold is the after iron oxide gold is pro
probably the most um biocompatible
material and that's why we use it
um
you can
and again we're talking about you know
people
getting it into tumors
um these are can be i think they can
basically sit there
without any long-term damage
um
also they
are typically removed out by
nanoparticles
by macrophage macrophages
now
another question i will address
is uh uh
for is uh
from colombia
and uh
what would be the risk of accumulation
of nanoparticles in the body organ
failure new tumor tumorogenesis
again you have to as i said before
we only use biocompatible nanoparticles
for this reason we don't use quantum
dots like which has selenium and cadmium
and things like that heavy metals
we're very careful to use um
essentially all the other components are
is already fda approved we're putting
them together
uh we
almost always avoid um any
excipient
entities which are not federally
approved so
um i think the
risk of organ failure and new tumor
genesis is
you know negligible and
will be minimized
um
do we evaluate liver or kidney toxicity
uh indeed we do and i didn't get into it
here i want to add that the local
chemotherapy has almost no systemic
toxicity outside of the tumor
the when you deliver systemic drugs they
do accumulate in typically in the liver
um and but there and then they're uh but
they can also be excreted out if they're
smaller than five nanometers renally and
then after that you can uh
others also through the biliary duct
okay
um
question here on um
can you comment about the performance of
dna-based nanocarriers
very interest very exciting stuff but
they're very very early
um and i think small structures are
being made
uh
however they are not they are not going
to be they cannot be administered
directly into the human body right now
uh because
they you know if you do they'll be
optimized anything
injected in the human body will be
eliminated almost immediately
will be optimized and then carried out
and shuttled out
so
um they would have to be
further processed
you know in order to make them long
circulating and then
to enter to get into the disease side
and that's a long ways ahead
but of course it's very exciting you
know
um there are a question here on and how
safe are inorganic nanoparticles over
liposomes i would say the only two that
we work with are gold and silica
um in nothing else um liposomes are
primarily lipid-based and all the
components are
are
are of course biocompatible i
i forgot to mention on the inorganic the
number one is iron oxide which is very
biocompatible you can administer grams
of it
gold is next and then silica after that
um
have you have any studies been done to
study the impact on um
microbiota
yes there's a lot of it uh we've done
some
you know uh i still have
and that's a separate talk by itself
aptomers and nano which of these is
patient friendly um you know
i think after merge well again i don't
want to
i mean there are people who are
passionately committed to aptomeris
um but i think there are some toxicity
issues associated with them that need to
be addressed
um
what are the main strategies for
targeting precisely the cancer cell as i
said we target the tumors
using
the epr effect or antibodies or magnetic
targeting
and then further on you can do further
targeting inside for instance when we
deliver parp inhibitors they're only
they only act on
on
mutant deficient cells like brocco
negative and they leave the other cells
alone so these are some of the overall
strategies that we use
um
so um i think um
i
at this point um
i want to thank you all
um
i've answered several of the questions
that were asked and i appreciate your
listening to me
um
and i hope you all um you know have
successful careers in your area of
research and um
good luck to you thank you very much